hello and welcome oh hello there et
today we're gonna give you an exclusive
tour of the Spellman house come on it
come on in over here we have a staircase
that leads to nothing at all and right
here we have a lot of people who have
signed their name in the Spellman
mortuary book someone says 10 out of 10
would die again another person that says
signed from the go8 you let go greatest
of all time or it could be the gokumon
himself
Oh Harry Potter Harry Potter was here
we've got a lot of rabbits you'll notice
a lot of bunnies and these shows um
you'll notice a nice flower arrangement
that's completely not real and you like
the Spellman house our friend over here
do you have anything to say for yourself
you've been in this house your whole
life nothing just crickets from this guy
Bob is shy okay yeah artwork as well as
something to definitely take note of
they're all very kind of eerie and cool
and Biblical feeling there's people in
waves and this one for example if you
walk down this hallway with us over here
we are going to walk into the mortuary
office this is a space that has up and
used a lot but when it it it when it is
it is used wisely we have a lot of
different candles over here we have
notes we have a desk
we've got coats and a clock I've only
been in this room once and it's kind of
amazing the detail and then obviously
the classic Sabrina stereo move where
she points her hand and it turns on
except it's all make-believe and I can't
really do that
[Music]
sabrina is going how to get her
boyfriend back I think that this season
is way more intense than the previous
season I think that the stakes are
higher and it's a lot more hell it's a
lot more kind of on the edge of your
seat what's gonna happen next sort of
moments it's it's big palace under new
management I think the love triangle
between Harvey Sabrina and Nick is going
strong this season mm-hmm I feel like we
see moments mm-hmm there's there's no
certainty at this point there's there's
some there's some declarations from
everyone that's happening there's
definitely definitely a season with a
lot of love and a lot of uncharted
territory and some some shakiness when
it comes to the romance side of
Sabrina's life yeah there's some rocky
roads ahead yeah sure it's not smooth
sailing no I don't know I just because I
because Sabrina is Harvey day one I'm so
sorry are are so loving it's so cute
there's a part of me that just wants to
see them together because there's a
young love but clearly Nicholas crotch
is dare I say the superior choice listen
to what I was so team hey Brina at first
'no Brina obviously I think it's
beautiful their love but I don't know
their love is real their love is
probably powerful and I think they're
better suited for each other but there's
the I think you can both I would be I
would be happy to see so we're gonna end
up with either gonna follow this really
big young man or boat yeah here we go
again we definitely get closer to
Riverdale this year than we did last
year I don't know if the crossover will
happen but we are teetering in that
direction yeah I would say so there's a
lot of hints there's a lot of little
Easter eggs to keep eyes open for oh my
gosh
I think Sabrina could really help out
the community over here retail well
equipped with some basic witchcraft ask
at you yeah yeah I just want to ride a
motorcycle with Jughead
mm-hmm that's it I think it'd be awesome
Nick is definitely a serpent and some
other life absolutely you would join
them in a heartbeat
Oh Betty's gonna lose her mind over this
I did post that photo oh man that's not
Sabrina's blood it's all I'll say is
that that photo is definitely Sabrina's
fault it's not her pulled on it
it's molasses it was summertime and
there were a lot of bugs now so so it's
basically I smelled like a pancake it
wasn't a bad smell yeah it was kind of
delicious my sheets smelled like it no
matter how many times I wash them they
still smelled like hmm well that's this
let's finish this usually pow wow
there's a lot of books and there is an
extraordinary couch usually this is my
seat I really like it over here and oh
I'm sorry what what kind of guest would
I be if I didn't offer you a drink
it's your poison I'll have an iced water
Oh two ice cubes
I'm sure they'll forgive you can I also
another thing to take note of is this
crazy beautiful glass ceiling goals am i
right
move the boom ceiling is absolutely
incredible
Isis Gavin Leatherwood oh man Karen you
already know this I tell you morning day
I know but I feel like she's the most
beautiful wonderful thanks for visiting
thank you so much guys that was a
Spellman house that was a Spellman house
et thanks so much for sticking with us
for this bellman house tour it's been
very fun I've enjoyed myself I've
enjoyed it as it Gavin mm-hmm and we'll
see a see on the screen part three Danu
area twenty-fourth here it comes
yeah 24th and on not just January 21 mmm
Claire fry can watch it after that
assault
[Music]